بودابست المجر هي جوهرة معمارية
بنيت من اتحاد ثلاث مدن ولا
شيء يرمز إلى هذا الاتحاد أفضل
من برلمانها الفريد من نوعه الذي تم بناؤه
للاحتفال بآلاف السنين من وجود المجر الذي
يطفو بأناقة على الضفة الشرقية
لنهر الدانوب البرلمان المجري
المبنى هو مثال
على العمارة القوطية الجديدة مع بعض
عناصر عصر النهضة والباروك التي تم
تكليفها في عام 1880 ، وتم
الانتهاء منها أخيرًا بعد 24 عامًا من ارتفاع 314
قدمًا وطولها 880 قدمًا مما يجعلها واحدة
من أكبر مباني البرلمان في
العالم.
شخص شاركوا في بنائه
حيث تم استخدام 14 مليون طوبة ونصف
مليون من الأحجار الكريمة و 88 رطلاً من
الذهب. الداخل موطن
للجمعية الوطنية المجرية
الفرع التشريعي للبلاد ،
وبقية المباني 10 أفنية
ومئات المكاتب كلها  مرتبط من
خلال نظام ممرات لا نهاية لها
وسجادة حمراء يبلغ طولها ما يقرب
من ميلين أحد المرتفعات  ts هو
تاج الأمة الذي يرتديه حوالي 50
حاكمًا ، أولهم حكم في القرن الثاني
عشر ومثل الكنوز الموجودة
داخل المبنى نفسه يضيء مثل جوهرة
في أفق هذه الأمة